-Good evening, I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing
well tonight.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're gonna get to the news.
President Biden
sent a letter today
to oil companies
and called on them
to produce more in order
to alleviate high prices.
So if you needed more proof
that he's an old man,
he still thinks you can get
things done with a letter.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
According to a new poll,
President Biden's
approval rating is at 40%,
meaning that his approval rating
is the only thing
inflation hasn't touched.
[ Laughter ]
Republicans Senator Tom Cotton
reportedly met yesterday
with two dozen of his top donors
to discuss a potential
2024 presidential campaign
and said that former
President Trump's candidacy
wouldn't prevent him
from running,
only from winning.
[ Laughter ]
After recent
congressional testimony
claimed that he was drunk on
the night of the 2020 election,
Rudy Giuliani tweeted yesterday
that he had refused all alcohol
that evening
and only drank Diet Pepsi,
although being drunk sounds like
the reason you give
for drinking Diet Pepsi.
"Dude, I was so
messed up last night,
I drank a Diet Pepsi."
[ Laughter ]
The K-pop group BTS
announced yesterday
that they're going on
an indefinite hiatus.
Said President Biden,
"Aw, man!
They're gonna blame me
for this, too."
[ Laughter ]
Elon Musk tweeted today
that he just voted Republican
for the first time,
but only because there were
no candidates running as Sith.
[ Laughter ]
Microsoft today formally
shut down Internet Explorer.
Well, technically,
it just shut down itself
and then they couldn't
restart it.
[ Laughs ]
A man in the UK recently
got a tattoo on his feet
that looks like a pair of shoes.
Said the man, "It hurt, but not
as much as the underwear."
[ Gasps, laughter ]
"There's just so much white."
Authorities in Michigan
recently discovered
an alligator
in the front seat of a car
during a traffic stop.
Even crazier, driver's side.
[ Laughter ]
And finally,
a cooking duo on TikTok
set a Guinness World Record
by creating the world's largest
chicken nugget.
Now, for the bad news.
[ Crowd groans ]
Scollins!
That was a monologue,
everybody.